[Music]
today for our daily cancellation we must
take a closer look at something that may
appear to be nothing but celebrity
gossip on the surface kanye west and kim
kardashian are going through a divorce
and which is a development that
surprises
only because it took seven whole years
of marriage before it happened i have no
opinion on the divorce itself except
that you better enjoy getting divorced
if you get if you marry a kardashian to
begin with
the issue of relevance today though is
the public feud between kanye and kim
pertaining to their eight-year-old
daughter north's social media use
now we'll leave aside the unfortunate
fact that these two decided to make
their daughter to name their daughter
north west
at least they named her based on compass
directions and not latitude and
longitude coordinates
northwest sounds better as a name than
like 34 degrees north 118 degrees west
uh but still northwest is kind of a
silly name in any case the
eight-year-old recently appeared on tick
tock with her own account and she was
posting videos
kanye did not approve and he said so
publicly and this prompted kim to defend
herself by going to tmz and the outlet
reports
sources close to the former couple tell
tmz north does not have her own
tick-tock account nor does she have the
app on her own phone any longer instead
we're told north can only access tick
tock through a joint account on kim's
phone and only uses it in her mother's
presence not just that but our sources
say the comments for north and kim's
account are fully disabled we've even
spoken to sources at tock who tell us
north and kim's account passes the
company's term terms and conditions for
minor miners now here's why kanye might
be in a tiff over this according to
another source in the no we know there
was in fact an incident recently where
north did go live on tick tock from her
own phone but our sources say kim
disciplined her over that and made the
changes then
really important reporting from tmz
so
what we can take from this is that
not only does the eight-year-old have a
tick-tock account but she has her own
phone
with internet access as well
at eight years old
now i'm not a fan of marital disputes
being aired publicly like this
especially when they have
children that are directly involved then
again kim kardashian and kanye west have
never really known how to speak to each
other or to anyone except through tmz so
there's no surprise there but putting
the method of communication aside does
kanye have a point
is his eight-year-old daughter too young
for social media
the answer of course is yes
obviously
without a question without any doubt
whatsoever
your young children should not be
anywhere near social media
they shouldn't have phones at all
now older children shouldn't really be
on social media either but the situation
is even more dire the younger the child
is also it's much easier to control what
a younger child does
an older child has more independence she
can drive you know she may have her own
means of income
so your ability to control her is not
entirely erased but but you have to rely
more on influence than control as the
child grows older and that's kind of
that's the process of parenting right is
that uh when the child is very very
young you're you are physically
controlling them a lot of the times if
you want them to go somewhere
you pick them up and bring them there so
you're exercising physical control
but as a child grows older
that physical control you start to rely
less on that and more on influence
you're trying to influence your child in
a certain direction
what about at eight years old
well she can't go anywhere unless you
take her there
she can't own anything unless you buy it
unless you're a fully
negligent parent you should know
generally where she is all the time and
what she's doing
even if you're not with her every second
of the day
if your eight-year-old has a phone and
the internet and social media it's
because you have not only allowed her to
do so but you have funded and
facilitated it
you have to pay for it
that is you have funded and facilitated
the damage that is being done to her
all that damage you are paying for it to
happen
this is very simple really
all we need to do is make a chart right
and this is this is a good way to
clarify a lot of things in life
make a chart
on one side you can list the negatives
of social media used for eight-year-olds
and on the other side list the positives
so let's begin with the positives
what is good about having your
eight-year-old daughter on social media
what are the objective benefits
well this is an easy list to fill out
because there's nothing on it
the closest thing to a benefit that
parents will cite for their young child
social media use is that all her friends
are doing it
well i don't want her to be left out
this is exactly the opposite of the sort
of advice my parents gave me as a child
when they constantly warned me that you
should not do things just because your
friends are doing them
if your friends are jumping off a bridge
would you do it too
was the classic rejoinder
and of course the answer to that was
yeah i totally would and did jump off of
bridges and other elevated structures
sometimes into water sometimes into
bushes or piles of leaves i did it
because it looked fun or because it
seemed funny at the time to hurt or maim
myself intentionally because i was a you
know that's what's that's what boys do
but social media is a different kind of
bridge entirely and once you jump off of
it you fall eternally into a bottomless
pit that eats your soul a little bit at
a time
the point is that kids may think
something is worthwhile because their
friends are doing it
because kids are immersed completely in
peer culture all they can see is what
their friends are doing
what matters most to them in the world
is acceptance from their peers it's the
only thing that matters to them for a
lot of these kids
it matters so much that these kids these
days will potentially kill themselves if
that approval and acceptance is withheld
that's how desperately they depend on it
and this is exactly why adults need to
be adults
they need to rescue their children from
this immersion
they need to see clearly where their
children cannot
an adult who encourages or allows social
media use on the basis that all their
friends are doing it is an adult who
thinks no clearer than the child he's
supposed to be in charge of
aside from the peer pressure defense all
the other positives of social media use
are really arguments for mitigated
negatives
and there's a whole lot of this
where you have parents arguing for
something as and making arguments as if
they're listing positives but actually
they're listing mitigated negatives
so when kim kardashian for example says
that she's monitoring her daughter's
internet activity she's not presenting
an item for the positive column
all she's doing is arguing that the bad
isn't quite as bad as her husband claims
yeah it's bad but i'm monitoring it
okay but that's not a good
even if i agree that you can mitigate
the bad when it comes to social media
use and i in fact i think that most of
the time you can't
but even if i agree that you could um
it's still not good
it's still objectively better for them
just not to be on it at all
you you can mitigate the risk
of driving drunk at 100 miles an hour
down the road by wearing a seat belt
i mean you it's it's if you're gonna do
it it's better to do it with a seat belt
than without
but that's not an argument that that
says that driving 100 miles down down
the road drunk is good
right the objectively better of course
would be to not do that at all
so what about the bad what goes in the
negative column
well we know that social media use
rewires our brains in an almost literal
way many studies have been not done on
this subject and there's quite a lot of
confirmation for for example the world
psychiat
psychiatric association's findings that
social media causes our brains to
experience effects similar to the sort
of cognitive decline that comes with age
right it turns us all into a bunch of
joe bidens
now imagine how that works in the in the
developing brain of a child
when social media causes cognitive
decline
and it's this is happening to a brain
that is still developing
and imagine how much worse it gets when
social media use begins practically at
infancy and lasts through a lifetime
you know when a child's brain
for a lot of us
people my generation
we we were kids and we had a real
childhood and our brains formed you know
um
despite maybe some of the brain damage
from jumping off of high of high
structures and that sort of thing
uh and then the internet came along
and messed us up
but at least we had a real childhood
first
where we did things like go outside and
play around we played tag and dodge ball
we went and ran around in the woods and
we you know we got our our our jeans
dirty and holes in the jeans and stuff
like that and we did all of that
and then the internet came along and
robbed us of the rest of our lives
and screwed up our
brains and that's bad
but imagine when a child's brain forms
around the internet because they are
immersed in it from birth practically
we also know that children are highly
susceptible easily influenced
on social media they're encountering a
mechanism designed by multi-billion
dollar companies with the express
purpose of influencing them of making
them addicted
letting your kid use social media it's
like letting them loosen a casino to
play on the slot machines slot machines
are expertly designed to put the user
into sort of trance
where they lose their free will and
continue playing even while they
bankrupt themselves and soil their pants
have you ever been to a casino by the
way it's always a little bit like
scandal is the first way if you've never
been to casino before you and you and
everything you learned about casinos you
learned from uh martin scorsese movies
or something like that and or james bond
and then you go to a casino for the
first time and you see that it's this
immensely depressing environment where
it's just a bunch of mostly people who
are over the age of 75
sitting there with their oxygen tanks
just staring at this at the slot machine
barely awake like zombies they keep
pressing this button they sit there for
hours
well the slot machine is designed to
have that effect
a lot of money went into doing that to
people
social media is meant to induce a
similar trance except it doesn't end
when you leave the casino
and also you know it's not 75 year olds
using it it's kids
add this to all the sexually charged
imagery the violent imagery and all that
that they're going to be exposed to
relentlessly hour by hour day by day on
social media and what you end up with is
a picture where
social media can do nothing but harm
them
that's the only thing it can do
it's not going to help them
it's not going to make them a better
person
okay there's no scenario
where you keep your kid from using
social media and then uh they turn 18
years old and you say to yourself ah man
i wish they had spent more time on
instagram
okay no parent is going to look back
at their experience as a parent with
their child and uh and they're in in
childhood and say to themselves you know
i wish i'd introduced tic toc earlier
no parent is going to say that
a lot of parents are going to say and
are saying right now
man
my kid is a zombie
i barely even recognize him
he is totally addicted to this stuff he
has no interest outside of it his life
completely revolves around this screen
he is being consumed by it
i wish i'd kept them away from it
because it can only harm them the
question is simply how much will it harm
them
and the answer is a lot
and that's why today
i must say that in this dispute kim
kardashian
is getting cancelled
if you enjoyed this video be sure to
give it a thumbs up and share it with
all your friends